show me where you gonna do that phone
there's some like that's fine thanks
just watch your head
Jamin would leave back
No
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States accompanied by
governor Lee of Tennessee
well thank you very much please this
afternoon I'll sign a proclamation
declaring the month of the maid to be
older Americans month I don't know if
I'm in that category I have a feeling I
am but I feel good and that our country
is making a lot of progress
Alex I won't tell you that making a lot
of progress as we honor the incredible
contributions of our nation's seniors
we're here today to discuss the
unprecedented steps that were taken to
protect our seniors from the virus
we'll also announced vital new actions
to safeguard our nursing homes and most
vulnerable citizens as we gradually in
safely reopen our country and it's very
exciting to see what's happening we're
joined today by secretary Alex azar
Thank You Secretary Robert Wilkie Robert
thank you very much administrators Seema
Verma Thank You great job FEMA
administrator Pete gainer a chief of
National Guard Bureau General Joseph
Lane gals thanks also to Tennessee
Governor Bill Lee my friend thank you
very much bill great job you're doing
it's great being with you too in many
outstanding advocates for America's
seniors who are here with us today thank
you all very much as we tragically have
seen the virus poses the greatest risk
to older Americans together as one
nation
we mourn for every precious life that
has been lost and there have been many
there have been many was so saddened by
it through our aggressive actions and
the devotion of our doctors and nurses
however we have held our fatality rate
far below hearted other countries such
as Spain and Italy and United Kingdom
and Sweden we're way below other
we're deploying every tool resource and
power at our disposal to protect our
seniors and Americans of every age in
background early on we implemented
life-saving travel restrictions and
directed billions of dollars toward the
development of therapies and vaccines
and that's moving along rapidly
we've moved at a speed that people are
absolutely stunned to see we accelerated
treatments including REM D severe which
is reportedly showing encouraging
preliminary results that was the very
big story yesterday was announced by
Gilead in early March my administration
advised all nursing homes to suspend all
medically unnecessary visits to help
slow the spread and to protect our
seniors and especially in our nursing
homes they are having a hard time in
those nursing homes we took action to
step up enforcement of infectious
disease standards at nursing homes all
across America we also acted swiftly to
secure our veterans health care
facilities and deployed hundreds of VA
staff to help out in nursing homes
nationwide and we're being helped very
greatly by the passage of all of the
things that we got past Robert
especially choice so that people can go
and see their doctor when they have to
and especially our seniors we provided
nearly 1 billion dollars in grants to
support home delivered meals in home
care and other services that make it
impossible for older people to just do
what they want to do we're helping older
people with disabilities and we're
helping them to live independently we
dramatically expanded access to
telehealth the very big deal for
Medicare beneficiaries the number of
Medicare
patients using telehealth has increased
from roughly 11,000 a week to more than
650,000 people a week so that's from
11,000 a week to 650,000 that's almost
impossible number to believe right but
it's really it's really something they
get used to it and a lot of that's going
to be staying with us long after this
horrible scourge is gone
Medicare is also paying for labs to
provide seniors with that home testing
when appropriate at zero cost to
patients we've ensured a ventilator for
every patient who needs one nobody who's
needed a ventilator has been without a
ventilator it's an incredible
achievement and we now have thousands
and thousands of ventilators and other
countries are asking us to help and
we're helping other countries allies and
some that aren't necessarily allies but
they're in big trouble and we're helping
other countries now with ventilators
same thing with masks we have millions
and millions of masks that was something
for weeks ago was difficult and now we
have millions of masks coming in and
already here the federal government is
also funding over 35,000 members of the
National Guard to help States deliver
critical supplies to nursing homes and
to assist with disinfecting and testing
I'd like to ask general lehnga to please
come up say a few words about the work
of the National Guard it's been really
fantastic thank you Joe please
Thank You mr. president and good
afternoon everyone I'm very proud of the
National Guard and all they are doing to
help keep our nation safe here at home
and abroad today over at 83,000 men and
women in the National Guard are engaged
at home and abroad and forty-five
thousand of those are engaged directly
in the Cova 19 response from running
hundreds of testing sites around the
country to screening passengers at
airports to helping manufacture PPE to a
myriad of other tasks the National Guard
is there we know this virus doesn't
treat everyone equally and our senior
citizens are at increased risk in many
states governors have directed National
Guard members to help sanitize long-term
care facilities nursing homes giving
older citizens and families and
caregivers peace of mind that their
environments are safe the Georgia
National Guard for instance has done
this has sanitized over 700 nursing
homes and this has been replicated at
many places around the nation that
continues to grow additionally food
banks and homeless shelters in normal
times these are often staffed by our
volunteers many of them are elderly
senior citizens here in the America now
volunteering puts those great Americans
at increased risk so the National Guard
is helping these Americans stay clear of
this risk and doing that the National
Guard is staffing many food banks across
the nation where they need the need for
food assistance is increasing across the
nation as this virus continues to
persist the National Guard is a big part
of our United States Army and our United
States Air Force and we're proud of that
but this role that we play here at home
in the homeland under the
the governor's in our states is
distinctly and uniquely National Guard
business and we're very proud of that so
mr. president thank you thank you for
the support that you give our military
in the National Guard and all the men
and women who serve they are proud to
serve our nation thank you for letting
to talk about the Guard unit thank you
sir four-stars it's a lot of stores very
impressive that's okay you deserve them
I do want to say you mentioned the word
governor and we've had a lot of great
success and relationship with the
governor's very very well we have really
I think God understand each other and
know each other in many cases really
like each other and that's worked out
very well
we had Phil Murphy here from New Jersey
Governor of New Jersey today wonderful
man a lot of progress is being made
there and we had John bel Edwards
yesterday from Louisiana and Ron de
santis today before from Florida but
just tremendous progress three very
exceptional men and they're doing a
really good job as you know as you know
so and we have others coming in to come
in one or two a day and we're seeing
them and whatever we can help them with
me help them with that we help them with
very very quickly general run so it's
been very good my administration is
doing everything possible to support the
state-led management of nursing homes
and here today is a governor who I
happen to like a lot and he's done a
fantastic job in a fantastic state a
state that I happen to like a lot it's
called Tennessee for some reason they
like me I haven't figured that out but
they like me in Tennessee so that's good
bill please come up governor Billy
please
thank you sir thank you very much mr.
president and thank you to your team
many in this room that we have worked
with you are guiding America through a
tremendous crisis and you're doing it
incredibly well and America's very
grateful for that
and we are grateful in Tennessee for the
partnership the partnership between the
federal government and states like ours
as we work to make our contribution to
fighting coke at 19 we can do so because
of the work that you're doing in the way
that you're supporting what we're doing
so mr. president you've asked States to
commit to a goal of testing 2% of their
population in April two percent of
Tennesseans were tested and we have
tested over a hundred and seventy-five
thousand to date but as we look to May
to to build upon that we were actually
strengthening a commitment particularly
to the elderly the most vulnerable of
our citizens especially those in nursing
homes you know there's a scripture
describes being hard pressed on every
side but not crushed and that's where we
are in Tennessee I think that's where we
are in a nation but the elderly are most
hard-pressed in this setting and
especially those in long-term care
facilities and they need our help
so in Tennessee were committed to
testing every resident and every staff
and every one of our 700 long-term care
facilities it'll be a great undertaking
but it honors the value of these lives
in those facilities lives that have
protected our country in the hardest of
times the greatest generation and those
that have a loving legacy of being our
neighbors our friends
grandparents and it's it's time for us
to protect them and we we should do so
pursuing social distancing for example
in every way that we can with them and
the distances sometimes a great gulf I
have an up my own elderly lawman in
eight weeks but we're doing right by
these citizens and you're doing right by
committing to these citizens to make
certain that they that we do our
personal part to make sure that they're
safe and while valuing our freedoms all
at the same time so well well I think as
a country we may be hard-pressed so many
sides we are not correct and we are
grateful for your leadership and for
this team's leadership and particularly
their commitment to the most vulnerable
in our nation and together we will get
through this thank you very much so
great governor by the way as we take
steps to safely reopen our country we
must remain especially vigilant in
sheltering the most vulnerable older
Americans to that end today I have
several important announcements first in
addition to all of these supplies we've
already distributed FEMA will send
supplemental shipments that I have to
tell you people what a job you've done
everybody was at the last go where the
governor so many of the governor said I
want to thank him for calling he called
on Easter morning and he's calling him
all the time when you call him when
Sunday's and you call them every time
all the time and I tell you they really
appreciate it
you've done a fantastic job Pete Gator
of FEMA but FEMA will send supplemental
shipments of personal protective
equipment to all 15400 Medicaid and
Medicare certified nursing homes in
America a second CMS is providing States
with 81 million dollars from the cares
Act to increase their inspections of
nursing homes at this very critical time
we have to do that we have to do that
and say it's a spot spot that we have to
take care of I guess you could call it a
little bit of a weak spot because things
are happening at the nursing homes that
we're not we're not happy about that we
don't want it to happen so we're
checking that out very carefully and
very methodically third this week we'll
be finalizing a new rule requiring
information about coronavirus cases and
nursing homes to be reported directly to
CDC and testing data to be posted online
so everyone gets to see it this rule
also requires nursing homes to report
cases to residents and their family
members and finally to ensure that our
nursing homes are prepared for any
future outbreaks we're announcing the
coronavirus Commission for safety and
quality and nursing homes this
commission will be composed of leading
industry experts doctors and scientists
resident and patient advocates family
members infection and prevention control
specialists and state and local
authorities it's a big deal the
Commission will convene in May and issue
recommendations the further steps we can
take to protect our nation's seniors
my administration will never waver at
its relentless commitment to America's
seniors we owe them a sacred and
unbreakable obligation and we will
fulfill that obligation with every
resource and power that we have we are
working very hard with our senior
be very hard with our nursing homes and
great progress is being made and will be
made that I can promise you that's also
why we are strongly protecting Medicare
and Social Security we will protect your
Social Security we will protect your
Medicare we will protect you as American
citizens and that goes even beyond
seniors we're protecting this country
our chair our seniors enrich every
aspect of our national life these great
citizens have dedicated their entire
lives to our families and our
communities and our countries our
country could not be anything near where
it is without our incredible seniors
we'll show them the same love and
loyalty they've shown us and they've
shown our nation every day of their
lives no effort will be spared to give
America seenu's the care and support and
devotion and love they have earned and
that they deserve in a few moments I'll
sign a proclamation zé's are designing a
very special we've designed a very
special plan and it's going to designate
older American Month so this is older
Americans month but first I'd like to
ask secretary is Secretary will key
administrator Verma administrator Gaynor
to share what their department and
agencies are doing to help our nation's
seniors so just coming up and maybe you
could say a few words and you've been a
lot of progress come Alex what are you
stuck well thank you mr. president for
your leadership during this pandemic and
for the work you've done throughout your
administration to protect older
Americans I'd also like to thank the
older Americans and advocates we have
here today including those working hard
at the state and local level as the
president described during this pan down
we have taken every possible effort to
keep older Americans healthy and safe in
addition to our public health and health
care efforts president Trump has secured
historic investments in programs for
older Americans and help them live
independently over the past month HHS
has dispersed more than 1 billion
dollars in grants to Aging and
Disability networks which are state and
local agencies like a Council on Aging
that provides services for seniors
living in the community this is more
than a 40 percent increase in the annual
support that we provide to these
critical organizations services that we
support they include delivered meals
like my grandmother used to get for
meals on wheels help with trips to the
grocery store or the doctor and
assistance with chores in the home back
in March we put out two hundred and
fifty million dollars in grants
specifically for meals including through
Meals on Wheels we've been pleased to
see communities get creative with these
funds some states are ensuring not only
that the meals are getting to seniors
but that the meals are coming from local
restaurants whose businesses are
struggling it's not just about meals and
services we also recognize that older
Americans may be facing mental health
challenges and feeling isolated
florida's aging Network for instance is
combating social isolation by providing
electronic tablets to nursing home
residents to help them communicate with
loved ones we're also working to protect
the rights of older Americans in
accessing health care our office for
civil rights has been taking action to
ensure that states and health care
providers do not discriminate on the
basis of disability or age in the
allocation of medical care we've already
had two states remove such
discriminatory policies from their
triaging guidelines as a result of our
office for civil rights work finally as
the president and others mentioned we've
worked closely with States to ensure
that they can test especially vulnerable
populations like those living in nursing
homes and those
for them this work to protect seniors
and empower them will continue
throughout the pandemic as we reopen our
country and keep America's seniors as
healthy and as independent as possible
thank you all for what you do in this
effort
mr. president thank you and thank you
for everything you have done to
transform the Department of Veterans
Affairs on behalf of the nation's nine
and a half
seventy-five years ago the men of the
28th Marine Regiment raised the American
flag on Mount Suribachi no event better
evoke the sacrifices and the triumphs
the 15 million Americans who put on the
uniform during World War two a few years
after he would Jima the soldiers of the
United States Eighth Army defended the
Pusan Perimeter and Marines fought
through and out of the Chosun reservoir
veterans of those terrible times are
still with us today early on in this
crisis President Trump gave me very
explicit orders to do everything
possible to protect the lives of those
precious Americans the Department of
Veterans Affairs has 134 nursing homes
but more than half of the residents in
those nursing homes fought in wars with
battles with names like Guadalcanal and
the Bulge and Incheon of the 78 thousand
residents in our nursing homes we have
tested all of them with the coronavirus
we have tested all of our staff in those
nursing homes our affection rate is low
many of our homes have few in any
positive cases but still as the
president noted we had to make a very
tough decision early on after all of
these veterans had gone through so much
on the battlefield we had to tell them
at this stage in their lives that we
were depriving them of the sustenance of
their family
and friends because we had to protect
their lives because of the president's
directions to me we have been able to
contain the virus in our nursing homes
and now we are taking those lessons that
we've learned from VA across the country
to protect patients across America we
are the federal experts in gerontology
we are helping 38 states and territories
handle the surge of patients dealing
with this virus with our partners our
great partners at FEMA and even by
direct action through the governor's
aiding America's elderly is central to
all of our evidence we deployed VA staff
as the president noted to veterans
nursing homes owned and operated by the
individual states early on governor's
Charlie Baker and Phil Murphy moved to
protect their veterans and they asked us
for help in addition to Massachusetts in
New Jersey we are helping in Alabama
Florida Tennessee in California and
Mississippi New Mexico Oklahoma Rhode
Island in Texas we have taken in non
veteran nursing home patients and state
veterans nursing home patients into our
VA facilities we are helping elderly
Americans wherever we find the president
you should be very proud of this VA that
you have helped build thousands of VA
employees have left into harm's way VA
leaders like Joan McInerney and Martina
Parata
Oh Ryan little had lost Rieman Nelson in
Detroit 50 brought in Illinois and
Wisconsin Fernando Rivera this guy mcdu
in New Orleans and Miguel Luz in Florida
all of them have put service before self
to protect the most vulnerable and
deserving these are the folks who made
America strong and free Thank You mr.
president and thank you for your
commitment to the nation's seniors and
to the Medicare program um you've been
very clear with me since day one that
you wanted to protect and strengthen the
Medicare program and under your
leadership our Medicare Advantage
program is seeing premiums at a 13-year
low and in our Part D program this is
seven-year low but today I want to focus
on nursing homes in the scheme of life
decisions placing a loved one in a
nursing home has to be one of the most
difficult decisions and when you make
that decision you want to know that you
can stay connected with your loved one
and that they're going to be safe and
have the best quality of life and that's
why the decision to restrict visitation
in nursing homes was a heartbreaking
decision and our thoughts and prayers
are with the families and the patients
during this very uncertain time but the
tragic reality is that the coronavirus
seemed almost tailor-made to put major
pressure on nursing homes in countries
across the world have struggled with
their nursing home populations for the
president's early action around nursing
homes has saved countless lives and even
before the coronavirus we have been
working on a strategy to improve quality
in nursing
homes the strategy focused on quality
oversight enforcement and transparency
for patients and their families so they
understand exactly what's going on in
nursing homes about the conditions there
and reducing regulatory burdens so that
nursing home providers can focus on
providing care to their patients instead
of paperwork we've overhauled the entire
survey system and implemented a common
tool across the entire nation to ensure
that our inspectors were being
consistent objective and that's actually
resulted in an increase in the number of
finds and we've updated our websites so
that patients and their families have
the latest information on the quality in
a nursing home and making it very clear
when nursing homes have had significant
cases of abuse and neglect and those
improvements that we've made made it
possible when the coronavirus hit for us
to take very rapid action on several
fronts we launched an unprecedented
transparency effort and that requires
nursing homes to informs patients and
families when there's an outbreak in the
nursing home and to also report that
information directly to the CDC and
that's going to be important to our
efforts around surveillance going
forward as we reopen the country and
also we increased reimbursement for labs
so that they could do more testing in
the nursing home and that's going to be
very critical as I said before tour
monitoring and surveillance efforts also
starting in February we issued a series
of nine guidance documents specific to
coronavirus and controlling infections
in nursing homes and just for some
perspective normally these types of
guidance documents can take months from
times a years but the CMS team work days
and nights and weekends to make
sure we got this information in the
hands of our nursing homes to do
everything that we could to protect our
vulnerable seniors and we also post
weekly calls with the nursing homes to
help them implement our guidance but
federal action is just one part of the
piece States ultimately licensed nursing
homes and that's why we've been working
with States to investigate outbreaks
that have been going on and inspect
nursing homes and our guidance has
called upon state and local leaders to
support nursing homes in their efforts
to control the corona virus outbreaks
and I commend governor Lee and governors
across the nation that have implemented
our guidance whether it's cleaning their
facilities testing and creating new
kovat facilities and that helps isolate
patients that are sick and keeps other
patients safe and this work has been
critical to keeping nursing home
residents safe and I'm pleased to
announce that we are putting out new
state grants to support state and local
efforts to nursing homes the president
has been an advocate of this he has
asked for increased funding to inspect
nursing homes every year in his budget
but this is the first time that Congress
has provided this funding and the money
couldn't come at a more critical time
it'll be important to work with our
state partners to ensure safety in our
nursing homes but the president has
directed us to do more and so as part of
our opening up America efforts we are
going to oversee the coronavirus
Commission for safety and quality and
nursing homes and the Commission will
comprehensively assess the response it
will identify best practices and also
provide recommendations for how we go
forward to protect our nursing home
residents and make sure we are providing
the best quality of life and in closing
I want to speak directly to our nursing
home residents their caretakers and
their families your pain is our pain and
we are doing everything we can to
support you and to the health care work
on the front lines providing care and
comfort to our nursing home residents we
thank you and thank you mr. president
for your consistent leadership and
unwavering support for our elderly
citizens thank you that's right we're
doing everything we can to lower the
price of insulin for our seniors and
we'll have some great announcements
coming out very soon to lower the prices
Thank You mr. president
administrator Verma and members of the
coronavirus task force let me focus on
the logistics in our effort to deliver
personal protective equipment care
packages to those citizens at highest
risk and greatest need those living in
our nursing homes across the country
thanks to the leadership of the
president and the tremendous support of
the white house corner virus task force
FEMA will deliver care packages
containing four items of PPE to more
than 15,000 medic Medicare Medicaid
certified nursing homes nationwide to
include the District of Columbia the
Commonwealth of Puerto Rico and Guam
given the lack of availability of PPE
necessary for health care workers
providing support for nursing homes we
will provide a packet or a kit
containing a seven-day supply of eye
protection masks gowns and gloves to
these 15-plus nursing homes each kit is
individualized for each nursing home
based on the level of staffing and the
seven days of our supply calculation
over the cost of the next 60 days when
providing each of the nursing homes with
two separate shipments of seven days of
supplies totaling fourteen days of
supplies by the beginning of July the
first shipment of supplies begins next
week these initial shipments will focus
on metropolitan area sites such as New
York City northern New Jersey Boston
Chicago and Washington DC the second
shipment of supplies begins in early
June the goal is to have all supplies
delivered no later than July
for assisting us in this endeavor is
federal resources a small business based
out of Stevensville Maryland who
specializes in chembio equipment support
with focusing on kidding solutions for
the Department of Defense they will help
us distribute the following PPE items
six hundred and eight thousand pieces of
eye protection 6.9 million surgical
masks 6.4 million gowns thirty 1.4
million pairs of gloves and finally I
again like to extend my gratitude to the
president for his leadership on this
project as well as to thank my fellow
members of the White House corner -
virus task force and their continued
partnership together we have turned a
critical demand for PPE for our seniors
in frontline Head health care workers
into reality
well thank you very much and we'd like
to have some questions by doing this and
we might venture into different
territorial so I think John yes yes by
the wise one but we said we could
venture straight into territory the vice
president said just a short time ago
people leave the General Michael Flynn
may have unintentionally lied to him or
misspoken when he talked to him well I
really have to talk to the vice
president but I'll tell you what general
Flynn was under enormous pressure and it
was an artificial pressure because what
they did to general Flynn was a disgrace
well it was a total disgrace it's
shocking and I hear even more
information came out today what they
tried to do to destroy him and to hurt
this presidency was perhaps in our
country's history there's never been and
if they like it an absolute disgrace but
I'll rely on what the vice president
said I can say this and I think you
understand this young very well what
happened to general flinch had never
happened again to a citizen of this
country yes please Michael Flynn would
come back
better so are you going to pardon them
and if so are you considering to bring
him back into your well it looks to me
like Michael Flynn would be exonerated
based on everything I see not the judge
but I have a different type of power but
I don't know that anybody would have to
use that power
I think he's exonerated everything I've
never seen anything like it what they
did what they wrote you see this general
you wouldn't want this happening to you
what they did to general Flynn and it's
just disgraceful so you know I guess
we'll get to that maybe someday but
maybe not hopefully we won't have to get
there well I think he's a fine man I
think it's terrible what they did to him
it's something that nobody's asked me
but you're asking me for the first time
I would certainly consider it yeah I
think he's I think he's a fine man
I think he's got a great family he loves
his son I will tell you his son was
around a lot and he loves his son and
says people generally do and they did
everything possible to destroy him
and he's still breathing very strongly
but they really hurt him very badly very
very unfair
Kristen quick follow in what well we
look I mean I'm not even this is really
the first time I've been asked a
question but I think he'll be fully
exonerated one way or the other and so
certainly he'd be capable of coming back
he's suffered greatly yesterday said
that the government's response has been
a quote great success story is that the
right lift that up a little bit problem
your son and lot one of your top
advisors Sharon Kushner yesterday said
the government's response has been a
quote great success story is that the
right tone and message
he's not talking about other things that
I talk about in my speech today that I
speak about all the time and that's
death it's horrible that what this
country has gone through and what the
world has gone to know frankly this is
something could have been contained at
the original location and I think he
could have been contained relatively
easily yes China is a very sophisticated
country and they could have contained it
they were either unable to or they chose
not to and the world is suffering
greatly but what Jared was talking about
and what I talk about a lot is no I
don't think anybody send the job that
we've done other than at public
relations because the press just won't
talk about the facts we had a a
ventilator problem that was caused by
the fact that we weren't left
ventilators by a previous administration
the cupboards were bare as they say
often and not only are the cupboards
full now we have ventilators with a king
in the world of ventilators we have
thousands and thousands of them now
being delivered you were at the news
conferences over the last few days the
governor's never they said we've never
had a case where we couldn't get a
ventilator and at that a month and a
half ago people you were screaming
ventilator ventilator I'm just looking
at the test numbers we have more tests
we've given more tests than the high
quality tests then every other country
combined and I said the friend of mine
South Korea president moon called me you
know they talked about South Korea and
they've done a really good job but he
said what a job you've done this is a
much bigger country you understand said
what a job you've done on on testing so
the testing and the masks and all of the
things we've solved every problem we
solved it quickly but to think that now
we're giving thousands of ventilators to
other countries allies and other than
allies to be honest but we're helping
other countries where people are dying
because we have ventilators and nobody
else does to this extent and it's a
great tribute I mean Deborah we were
talking about that
for deborah birx dr. Berkshires has been
fantastic she's a fantastic person
fantastic woman and we talk about the
things that we've done in a short period
of time I mean all you heard about was
ventless that's a hard thing we
energized factories that didn't build
ventilators they were building cars and
other things and now we're building
thousands a week and it's been a very
spectacular it's been really spectacular
so yeah I think I don't think anybody's
done a better job with testing with
ventilators with all of the things that
we've done and our death totals our
numbers four million people are really
very very strong we're very proud of the
job we've done we had very little to
work with because the previous
administration left us very well I need
it and I sign it and we do have
executive orders and they helped us a
lot and they've helped us a very lot
here we also sign things having to do
with production as you know I've used
that very very powerfully the act and
often times I didn't have to use it I
just had to talk about it
now I'm only signing when we want
something what we want when we need
additional manpower or brain power or
whatever it is we're looking for at the
time but we again we've done things that
I don't think anybody else has been able
to do what we've done and this would be
country to there's a very big country as
you know and I'm very proud of the
country I'm very proud of the way they
they've stepped up now things are
opening as an example governor Lee is
doing a great job in opening up
Tennessee and he's opening it up rapidly
and safely I think he said to me two
words I think about safe and rapid and I
think safe was the first one you
mentioned in all fairness but
was safe and rapid he's doing it quickly
and safely and Tennessee's a great story
but we have other governor's friends of
both of ours that are doing really a
good job I will say this governor Murphy
and Governor Cuomo have a tougher
situation because that's really a hotbed
that's a very very dense area people
don't realize I think New Jersey believe
it as the single most dense area in the
country who would think that but the
governor's done a terrific job and
Governor Cuomo likewise is working very
very hard and speaking to me all the
time and whenever we can help him we do
and we're helping him and he's helping
his state this what he has to do thank
you I think the operation is doing
really well I think that things are
being discovered that you wouldn't have
thought possible the Abbott machined
Abbott Laboratories a great great
scientific company they came up with a
machine that I would say two months ago
nobody ever heard of this machine and
all of a sudden boom people come into my
office they get tested it takes them
five minutes so they feel very good some
of them have never been tested but these
are you know equipment and equipment and
and tests that nobody ever thought even
possible three or four months ago we're
being being used commonly now I looked
at the numbers and we're over six
million tests and you add up everybody
together they don't have anywhere near
that so it's it's an incredible thing
and it'd be great if the media could
really portray it the way it is because
we've done some unbelievable work and
when somebody uses the word successful I
mean it really has been successful it's
been very successful but if you look at
mortality and mortality rates you know
this country it's a very sad thing to be
talking about who ever thought you'd be
talking about such a thing
two months ago was about all we talked
about was the economy how well it was
going but today we have to talk about
that
our country has really stepped up our
generals have stepped up in our
most have stepped up for the way I'd
roll has done a fantastic job as you
know and you know we're very proud of
everybody this whole room has been very
amazing okay who's next well China
doesn't want to see me elected and the
reason is that we're getting billions
and millions of dollars many billions of
dollars a month from China China never
gave our country anything Johnny gave us
nothing not ten cents and whether it was
Biden in charge of China which was a
joke because he ripped off they ripped
off our country for eight years and they
no fairness to Biden and Obama this one
oughta long before they got into office
and you can go through many
administrations until I came along and
then we signed a trade deal the way
they're supposed to buy and they've been
buying a lot actually but that now
becomes secondary to what took place
with the virus the virus situation is
just not acceptable I don't want to put
any caste any dispersions I just will
tell you the China would like to see a
sleepy Joe Biden they would take this
country for a ride like you've never
seen before
mr. president I didn't mr. president mr.
president mr. president right
in numbers coming out today 30 million
now unemployed have you given any
thought to possibly extending the six
hundred extra dollars of unemployment
benefits that are that are given that
now they will run out and that we run
out live they are looking at it and
they're taking a very strong look and
will be reporting to you very shortly I
will say this obviously this is what it
is it's this period of time but I think
I view the third quarter as a transition
quarter and I think you're gonna have a
very strong transition and then I think
the fourth quarter is going to be
incredibly successful I think next year
we're gonna have a phenomenal year
economically well I don't want to say
that I don't want to say that but
certainly it could have been stopped it
came out of China and it could have been
stopped and I wish they stopped it and
so does the whole world which say stuff
mr. president unemployment there are
many businesses who are concerned that
is America opens back up again because
of a provision in the Care Act right
gives an additional $600 they won't be
able to get their employees back because
they make more money staying at home
than they would if they come back and
came back to work we just caused some
governor's to suggest that they might
strip those people of their unemployment
insurance if they refused to go back to
work is that something you would support
well we're looking at a lot of different
things I brought this up before I was
done this was a Democrat point and I
said you know some people are going to
be treated unfairly and some people to
be treated you know they did
get into the kind of formulas the way I
saw it I said exactly that this was
going to happen but when you think about
it it's basically we're being generous
with people that it's short-term and
we're being very generous with people
that lost their jobs or potentially what
was their jobs so it's not the biggest
problem that I've ever heard of they're
getting a little bit more money in some
cases they're getting more money than
they thought they would have gotten a
lot of employees are saying no the job
is more important because the employer
is not going to forget that and but it
was something that I brought up at the
beginning and nobody wanted to listen
Joe Biden your campaign and surrogates
going after him pretty hard with regard
to these allegations from Tara Reid what
do you say to help ID so I don't think
they're going after him hard with regard
to Terry Collins and what do you say to
Joe White I don't know anything about it
I don't know exactly I think he should
respond you know it could be false
accusations like know all about false
accusations I've been falsely charged
numerous times and there is such a thing
if you look at if you look at Brett
Kavanaugh there's an outstanding man he
was falsely charged what happened with
him was an absolute disgrace to a
country and I guess three of the four
women have now admitted that and of the
fourth give me a break I mean take a
look 36 years that is look this is a
fine man I saw a man suffering so
unfairly I'm talking about Brett
Kavanaugh so but I don't know I can't
speak for Biden I can only say that I
think you shouldn't respond I think you
should answer them thank you sir on
China a moment ago you said that China
it's possible they could chose and not
to stop the spread of the virus are you
insinuating they intentionally let it
spread well they've done it and I'm just
saying well one of two things happened
I'd either
didn't do it and you know they
do it from his competence and point or
they let it spread and you know I would
say probably it was it got out of
control but you know there's another
case that how come they stopped to all
the planes and all of the traffic from
going into China but they didn't stop
the planes and the traffic from coming
into the United States and from coming
into all over Europe I mean look at
Italy look what happened to Italy and
it's very lucky this country is very
lucky and I'm very lucky that I put the
ban on China as you know very early on
in January we put the ban on in China
and that was a very early day that
wasn't a late day that was an early day
then we later put the ban on in Europe
and if we we didn't do that as Alex
knows we would have had a problem like
you wouldn't have believed we would have
had a problem much bigger but then you
take a look at what happened to Italy a
lot of those people went to Italy
instead and it's been a very very tough
place Italy and then I'm holding them to
cap on the hold them accountable is that
something you prefer to do now in the
next so I want to find out what happened
I think we'll be able to get a very good
very powerful definition of exactly what
happened we're working on it strongly
now and I think it's going to be very
powerful but they could have stopped it
they are a very brilliant nation
scientifically and otherwise it got
loose let's say and they could have
capped it they could have stopped it but
they didn't and but they stopped playing
so I'm going to China but they didn't
stop them from going to the rest of the
world what was that all about you
so what's changed when you tweeted it
Chinese been working very hard to
contain the growing a virus the u.s.
greatly appreciates their efforts and
transparency it will all work out well
what has changed between then when you
were saying those things about China and
now
well what's changes the following we did
a trade deal and everybody was very
happy
there's nobody ever been tough on China
like I've been tough on China I got
elected at least partially because of
borders and military and different
things but one of the things I'd say is
have China and other countries are
ripping us off so recently we signed a
trade deal with China a number of months
ago Chinese buying billions of dollars
worth of a product our farm product and
other product manufacturing product and
it's been a great deal but then we
noticed a virus and it's not acceptable
what happened it came out of China and
it's not acceptable what happened and
now what we're doing Jim is we're
finding out how it came out different
forms you know you've heard all
different things you've heard three or
four different concepts as to how it
came out we should have the answer to
that in the not-too-distant future and
that will determine a lot how I feel
about China but when I was of course I
was very rough with China
I mean Biden as an example the previous
administration
they let China rip off this country like
nobody's ever ripped off this country
now what I did is I took that I took
that I'm doing that and I made it into a
great deal for our country but after
that all of a sudden we're there's a
virus and the virus is coming in that
changes my mind very greatly that's a
whole different thing so you could have
good trade deals that was girl you're on
the trade deal they made the
earlier on and it's a great deal when
we're taking in billions and billions of
dollars of money in different forms
including the fact that we have a 25%
tariff on two hundred and fifty billion
dollars it's a tremendous amount of
money some of that money I've given to
the farmers because they were targeted
by China and I gave 12 billion dollars I
gave 16 billion dollars and this year
we're going to be givin giving
approximately 19 billion dollars to the
farmers but well something happened
something happened I don't say
misleading or not I'll let you know that
I mean I'll be able to give you that
answer at some point and they hopefully
not too distant future but I will tell
you that you take a look at what
happened to this world a month and a
half two months ago we had the strongest
economy in the history of the world and
all of a sudden I have to close the
economy have to close the country so
we've had tremendous death and sermons
tremendous sorrow sadness and nobody's
ever seen anything like it and so have
most of the countries of the world most
think of that most of the countries 184
you tell me it's probably low right now
because I've been saying 184 184
countries they've suffered tremendously
it's something that is going to have to
be dealt with on the issue
Vice President Biden has said you should
lower the White House flag to half-mast
are you going to do that and are you
thinking about leading the nation in a
mission I wouldn't have minded that I
would say not only the White House flag
we could we could do that effect it's
something that I will be talking about
later or whatever
on various things that's one of the
topics and we're going to bring that up
so I think lowering the flags would be
something very appropriate about leading
the country though in a moment of
mourning for all of the lives lost the
more than 60-thousand of course again I
don't think anybody can feel any worse
than I do about all of the death and
destruction
that's so needless nobody but I also
have to make sure that we handle the
situation well nobody's thinking about
it more nobody nobody has spent more
time late in the evening thinking about
what's happened to this country in a
short period of time but at the same
time we have to get our country open
again and we're doing that step by step
Tennessee is an example step by step
we're opening up our country and I
really believe that next year we can be
maybe even beyond we have a lot of
stimulus and maybe even beyond we'll see
about by the way package for phase 4 but
I really hope that we can be as good or
better
I built it once and we're going to build
it again you said a moment ago you will
soon have information on where this
virus originated the Director of
National Intelligence today put out a
statement saying that they believe it
was naturally occurring was not man-made
but who is that who is that - said the
Office of the Director of National Zoo
in particular who was the man who made
this way there was a statement that the
you would know that
so we'll see I would be your French
national intelligence well now I think I
think it's I mean you'd have to tell me
who specifically who made the statement
the statement was just put out under the
office of the NDC I may not have to see
the same but I just haven't seen but the
question I had was have you seen
anything at this point we look even
separately from but we're looking at
exactly where it came from
oh it came from how it happened
separately and also scientifically so
we're going to be able to find my
question is have you seen anything at
this point that gives you a high degree
of confidence that the Wuhan instituted
virology was the origin of this virus
yes yes I am and I think that the World
Health Organization should be ashamed of
themselves
because they're like the public
relations agency for China and this
country pays them almost 500 million
dollars a year and China pays them 38
million dollars a year and whether it's
a lot or more doesn't matter it's still
they shouldn't be making excuses when
people make horrible mistakes especially
mistakes that are causing hundreds of
thousands of people around the world to
die I think the World Health
Organization should be ashamed of
themselves well I have the right to do
that but sanctuary cities especially at
a time like this that's a very dangerous
thing our law enforcement hates it they
hate it they want we want safe cities we
want sanctuary but we want sanctuary for
our citizens and we don't want sanctuary
for criminals that came into our country
illegally and they have big records and
records I will go into the type of
crimes but the crimes are the ultimate
and evil in many cases no we don't want
them to have sanctuary in our country we
want to have strong borders look I said
again we want to have strong borders
I've been saying this for a long time
and I think people are agreeing with me
I really
do I think people are agreeing with me
the Democrats won't have open borders
where people just come in and you're not
only talking about coming in from a
crime standpoint you're now talking
about coming in with not only the
disease that we happen to be talking
about so much lately but other diseases
and they want to have open borders they
want people to pour into our country
from know from who knows where they come
no we're not doing that we have a very
strong border now or southern border and
every day gets stronger because we're
building miles a day of very very
powerful walls and that's a great thing
for a country that's so important for
our country and very few people are
arguing with it so it is a war and I
define victory when it's gone and we
opened successfully we have a successful
country again now it can never be a
total victory because too many people
have died all over the world people have
died in our country in every country I'm
looking at the new list of countries
look at what's going on with Russia look
at what's going on with Spain is so so
incredibly harmed and injured by this so
many people are dying this is this is
not something where you'll go to your
traditional G this was an experience
this is not an experience it's a very
bad experience but what I want is we
want the virus gone and we want to have
a vibrant economy we want people back we
don't want people necessarily sitting
like these incredible people in front of
me where they're sitting 6 feet apart
and that I mean the I want our country
back I want people to go a you know out
and see football games and baseball
games and basketball and hockey and golf
and all of these sports and not worry
about getting sick and violently ill one
of the things that was very interesting
you probably saw it we put it out before
though was Sweden and you compared the
deaths and
Sweden to Denmark and and Finland and
Norway and you know I hate to say it but
the deaths are very very substantially
higher in Sweden because they've used
that as an example Brazil is very high
if you look at what's gone on the graph
graphically very very high very very
straight up almost right Deborah very
straight up friend of mine great
gentleman president of Brazil he's
really a friend of mine is a great man
but they haven't a hard time they going
heard Sweden won hurt but you know when
they say heard it's really in Sweden in
particular the bars you can't go to
certain areas you can't go to a lot of
the people are saying well the Prime
Minister's doesn't have to say stay in
your apartment stay in your house
they're staying there they're not
leaving so you know it's really not
quite what was reported but the number
of deaths are tremendous and Sweden
compared to the countries that surround
where they did where they did very
strong lockdowns and we were discussing
that Deborah before it's a very big
difference it's a very big difference
but again as sweet didn't go really
heard as you understand it and also the
people of Sweden very smart this thing
in the houses they're staying and
they're not going out and let's know or
some yeah I guess so but they've lost a
lot of people in Sweden yes just a
second ago
I missed the in the interruption did you
are you suggesting that maybe you have
some evidence that this was not a
naturally occurring virus we're gonna
see one of these you talking about the
virus and right where it came no window
to see where it is we're gonna see where
it comes from and you know look you've
know every theory
the theory from the lab yet the theory
from many different the bats and no the
type of that and the bat is 40 miles
away so it couldn't have been here and
it couldn't have been there and we have
up there's a lot of theories but yeah we
have people looking at it very very
strongly scientific people intelligence
people and others and what if we're
gonna put it all together I think and
what gives you one might might even tell
us china may tell us and and what gives
you a high degree of confidence that
this originated from the Wuhan Institute
of Virology I can't tell you that I'm
not allowed to tell you that mr.
president would you consider having the
United States not pay its debt
obligations to China as punishment for
the virus well I could do it differently
I can do the same thing but even for
more money just by putting on tariffs so
I don't have to do that you know it's a
part it's approximately a trillion
dollar it's a little bit more as I
understand a trillion dollars but we
could do that in a I think probably a
little bit of a more forthright manner
you start playing those games and that's
tough you know we have the dollar to
protect we want to protect the sanctity
of the dollar and the importance of the
dollar it's the greatest currency in the
history of the world it's become
stronger we have a very strong dollar
that's why we're borrowing at zero zero
interest rate you know with all of the
stimulus that we're talking about where
that sounds good that general doesn't it
we're paying zero interest so
essentially right around zero but zero
and you want to protect it's a very good
question you know if you say ho gto is
we owe you a certain amount of money
we're going to keep it but when you
start playing that game you're really
hurting the sanctity the importance of
the greatest currency on earth but we
can do it in other ways we can do it
with tariffs we can do it other ways
even beyond that without having to play
that game that's a rough game speaker on
a separate topic but related speaker
Pelosi said
that she envisions up to trillion
dollars needed to help support states
and localities would you support that
figure so what's happening is the
Democrats have come to us and they'd
like to do a phase four and we'll think
about what's happening they want to help
the states they want help bailouts and
you know bailouts are very tough and
they happen to be Democrat states it's
California it's New York its Illinois
you start with those three and the
Republican states are in strong shape
you know I don't know is that luck or is
that talent or is it just a different
mentality but the Republican run states
are instruction look I looked today when
I spoke I spoke with Rhonda Sanchez who
was here yesterday as I said florida's
doing incredibly Texas is doing
incredibly these states are doing
unbelievably they don't know about the
word bailout we had a call from the
governor of South Dakota and they have
one of the finest ruin states they have
they I think a constitutional amendment
they're not allowed to you know they
have to have a balanced budget and they
have a balanced totally balanced budget
they just have a sales tax it's about
the only tax they have is a sales tax
and to think of it so it's a whole
different thing but Republican states
are doing very well maybe the Democrats
should have brought this up earlier when
we wanted certain things and they did
and we said and I said it specifically
now let's look at it later on down the
road but they'd like to do something
they want to do infrastructure I can
understand infrastructure think of it
we've spent eight trillion dollars in
the middle east and we're not fixing our
roads in this country how stupid how
stupid is it and we're not fixing our
highways our tunnels our bridges our
hospitals even our schools even it's
crazy but but they want to do things and
the Republicans are in a much better
position from you know I don't want to
use the word negotiating position but
we're really uh we're a negotiating
position that's different because they
want to bail out various states Illinois
is in big trouble
the governor understands that Pritzker
he understands that but Illinois is in
big trouble is it fair to do that and
then have states that are very powerful
and strong like Iowa and I know
Idaho let me take Idaho look at look at
all of these incredible states and look
at what's going on and how successful
they are so you just take a look and and
we're going to look at it we're going to
look at it I think we want to take a
little bit of a pause but if we do that
we'll have to get something for it Oh
question on masks but very quickly to
follow up on Jeff it sounds like you're
potentially open to leader McConnell's
call that states should apply for
bankruptcy is that what you're saying he
threw that out again spoken to him about
about it very strongly and we're gonna
see what happens we'll take a little bit
of a pause we'll see what happens but
some states are in trouble I spoke today
I was with a wonderful man a great
gentleman wonderful human being I think
bill knows them too from new jersey
governor phil murphy and we talked about
it you know new jersey is a it's a
wonderful state i have to say it's a
wonderful place but it's got a lot of
difficulty in terms of the economics and
the debt the costs etc so it's in a
different position than some of the
other states that we could mention we
could mention him all day long
masks if I could vice president pence
did not wear one when he visited the
Mayo Clinic earlier this week he's
wearing one today you are traveling to
Arizona will you wear a mask what is the
policy for emergency
I look forward to that I'll have to see
the climate I mean I'm gonna look at see
you know where I am here's the place
that we all feel very comfortable
everybody spread out it's a very big
room but as far as where I'm going in
Arizona I'm gonna have to look at the
climate I'd have no problem wearing a
mask
I don't know I'm supposed to make a
speech I just don't know should I speak
in a mask you'd have to tell me if
that's politically correct I don't know
if it is oh speaking of mists but but I
have I'm gonna be making a speech in
Arizona I look forward to it and
depending on the conditions I would have
no problem wearing a mask oh we have
millions of masks now you know we have
masks coming in that there was another
thing it was very hard to get masks we
now have and we're making millions and
millions of masks they're opening plants
and it's been incredible well I didn't
hear what he said I can only tell you
that I see it I think it's going to be a
transition quarter the third quarter I
think the fourth quarter is going to be
very good and I think next year's going
to be fantastic because of the stimulus
and I haven't seen a statement but I
think we're gonna have a great year next
year knowing that we left behind a year
of tremendous death tremendous death it
was just a terrible thing the likes of
which we haven't seen I guess if you go
back over a hundred years 1917 and that
was a terrible thing but that was close
depending on your your account or the
account anywhere from fifty to a hundred
million people that 1917 so we haven't
seen it it's over a hundred years and so
understanding that that was terrible I
think that next year from from an
economic standpoint I mean look at the
stock market people are amazed the stock
market's at over 24,000 well it was it
twenty nine thousand twenty four
thousand now is that even possible
considering what we've gone through
because people are very smart they're
very many of these people are very
brilliant and they look and they they
see a great future the other thing the
dollar is very strong so when we go out
and do stimulus packages were
oversubscribed at zero I'm think of it
you get your money back at zero it's a
pretty incredible thing the euro is
having a hard time and it's much smaller
the dollar has really become the dollar
is king in the dollars at a position now
it's just a very powerful it's a very
powerful thing the dollar other
currencies of Murray in big trouble
they're really in big trouble whereas
the dollar is very powerful very strong
so the good part about that is if you do
go out and if we do want to do stimulus
or whatever we want to do we're
borrowing at zero and the dollar is very
strong we're going to see so far I think
John has been trying to be or at least
they seem to be trying to be somewhat
transparent with us but we're gonna find
out you'll be learning in the
not-too-distant future but it's a
terrible thing that happened whether
they made a mistake or whether it
started off as a mistake and then they
made another one or did somebody do
something on purpose saying hey you know
I I don't understand how traffic how
people weren't allowed into the rest of
China but they were allowed into the
rest of the world that's a bad that's a
hard question for them to answer if
you've got an update on his condition
and whether it use a life or death well
I understand what's going on
and I just can't talk about Kim jong-un
right now I just hope everything is
gonna be fine
but I do I do understand the situation
very well please we talked about being
complementary of China early on were you
saying that you were complimentary of
China because you were concerned about
the try making a trade deal with China
this was before the virus of course
they're gonna be complementary now it
was very uncomplimentary prior to that
negotiation and then every once in a
while the negotiation would break down
because I'm not like Kerry who signed
the worst deal of the Iran deal which
was such a disaster and he never left
the table I left the table a lot anyway
we ended up making a deal and of course
during the course of the deal I was both
complimentary and very uncomplimentary
but the bottom line is we ended up
making video before the virus came and I
was very happy with the deal but then
later on that was superseded by a virus
that should not have happened
well I just want to thank you all very
much and we'll see you probably tomorrow
sometime thank you very much
[Music]